ce discours
une longue liste non pas de
récrimination mais d'exigence de la de
l'Ukraine contre la Russie en disant
pour résumer finalement il l'a répété à
plusieurs reprises la Russie doit payer
il faut punir la Russie c'est une des
conditions à la paix qui est venu de la
part de les dernières zeninski qui
finalement avait donné l'impression de
parler un peu en position de force après
ce qui s'est passé sur le terrain
militaire avec de très nombreuses
exigences pour pour la paix par
évidemment du retour à l'intégrité
territoriale mais effectivement vous
l'avez dit aussi de Ce privé la la
Russie de son droit de veto mais aussi
d'établir a-t-il demandé un tribunal
spécial pour l'Ukraine et puis de
demander d'exiger des compensations qui
devraient être payées par la Russie donc
un discours extrêmement ferme de ce
point de vue là qui s'adressait à
l'immense la majorité des pays du monde
qui soutiennent l'Ukraine parce que il
l'a rappelé dans les chiffres et on
vient de l'entendre plus d'une centaine
de pays par exemple qui ont voté pour
autoriser la volody mirzelinsky a parlé
en vidéo contre les 7 habituels soutient
6 soutiens de la Russie plus la Russie
qui s'y sont opposés manière finalement
pour lui de rappeler que l'immense
majorité des puissances des pouvoirs des
pays du monde sont finalement dans le
camp de de l'Ukraine face à dans ce
combat face à la Russie